افادت مصادر وقضائيه في لبنان بانطلاقه
جلسات الاستماع الى حاكم مصرف لبنان
المركزيه رياض سلامه تنفيذا للاستنابات
القضائيه الاوروبيه واستكمالا للتحقيق
الذي بداته دول اوروبيه قبل سنتين وركزت
تحقيق على التحويلات الماليه من حسابات
حاكم المركزي وشقيقه رجع الى مصارف
اوروبيه وتحديد مصدر هذه الاموال على ان
يدير هذه الجلسات التي ستستغرق ثلاثه ايام
قاده تحقيق الاول في بيروت شربل ابو سمره
بحضور الوفود الاوروبيه التي وصلت الى
لبنان لهذه المهمه
[موسيقى]
نعم صباح الخير انها الساعه العاشره ونصف
تماما بتوقيت بيروت هذا هو الموعد الرسمي
لانطلاق جلسه استجواب رياض سلامه نحن خارج
قصر العدل بمطلق الاحوال هذه البوابه
الرئيسيه خلفي شهدت دخول الوفد القضائي
الاوروبي لكننا لا نعلم اذا كان رياض
سلامه اصبح في الداخل ام لا لانه بمطلق
الاحوال قد يسلك مدخلا اخر الوفد الاوروبي
اذا وصل قبل حوالي ربع ساعه من موعد
انطلاق المحاكمه هي المره الاولى التي
سيمثل بها سلام امام القضاء الاوروبي اذا
هو مطلوب بموجب استنابه قضائيه اوروبيه
وليس بموجب الدعاوي التي مرفوعه عليه من
قبل القضاء اللبناني الوفد الاوروبي يراسه
يعني تتواجد فيه قاضيه فرنسيه تمثل فرنسا
والككسمبورغ وممثل قنصل المانيا وهم
سيشاركون في هذه الجلسه دون القدره على
طرح اسئله مباشره الى الى سليمه بما يتعلق
بالسياده القانون واستقلاليته لذلك من
يدير هذه الجلسه هو القاضي شربل ابو ابو
سمره وكان الوافد قد القاضي ابو سم في
مكتبه وقد اتفقوا على سير هذه
العمليه ليوم امس ويحكى عن اكثر من 100
سؤال سيتم طرحها على سلامه بما يعني انه
اذا حضر اليوم لن تكون جلسه الوحيده بل قد
تمتد على ايام ثلاث لنظرا يعني كثره
الاسئله وايضا القضاء الاوروبي سيطلب
الاستماع الى شقيقه رجا والى مساعدته
معاونته ماريان الحويك الكل اذا متهم
بالقضاء الاوروبي باختلاس اموال بتهرب
ضاربي وبتبيض اموال ايضا رينا يعني رغم
الشكاوى والتحقيقات ومنع السفر لرياض
سلامه الا انه لا يزال
بمنصب منذ العام 1993
يعني تنتهي ولايته هذا العام بايار بمايو
هل يمكن لهذه التحقيقات ان يعني تنهي هذه
الولايه الطويله
هل من مؤشرات على ذلك بالاجواء اللبنانيه
لانه عاده التصريحات يعني التصريحات عاده
سيتم التمديد له او لا
اعتقد انه ولايه ستنتهي في نهايه
مايو ولكن يعني قد لا تنتهي قبلها هذه
التحقيقات بمطلق الاحوال رياض سلامه يشغل
منصبه كما قلت من اكثر من ثلاثين عاما
وبذلك يكون يمكن اطول حاكم في حكام في
تاريخ حكام المراكز المصرفيه هو رغم كل
الدعوه التي بحقه ومنع السفر الذي سطرته
القضيه غدا الا انه لا يزال على منصبه حتى
يومنا هذا اذا كان سيحضر او لا يحضر هذا
هو السؤال البديهي الذي يمكن ان يطرح الان
كوننا لا نعرف اذا كان داخل اروقات العدل
ولكن المعلومات كلها تقاطعت عند حضوره هذه
الجلسه شخصيا لاسباب تتعلق بعدم يعني ليس
في وارد ان يتخلف عن الاجراءات الاوروبيه
من جهه ومن جهه اخرى كون وكلائه
القانونيين لم يقدموا اي دفوعا شكليه
بالنيابه عنه لعدم الحضور فنحن ايضا نترقب
مشاركه رياض سلامه في جلسه اليوم سيكون له
محاميان واحد فرنسي واخر لبناني وستكون
ستشهد
جلسه الاستجواب وجود مترجمين اثنين
سيعملان على نقل الاسئله من القاضي ابو
سمره الى
الى رياض سلامه نعم شكرا جزيلا لك
رينادوايه من امام قصر العدل في بيروت حيث
جلسه الاستماع الى رياض سلامه بحضور وفد
اوروبي بتهمه اختلاس اموال
الشعب اللبناني